وما لا يقبل التشكيك يا طاهر انا الانتظار
الاوكراني الكبير كان بمثابه انتكاسا
روسيه كبيره جعلت صقور الحرب الروسي
يصعدون انتقاداتهم نحو الجيش وبوتن للمره
الاولى وجها ان نشطاء المؤيدون للحرب في
روسيا اكثر انتقاداتهم لاداء الجيش في
اوكرانيا بعد الانسحاب المهين من خير كتب
الكسندر دورين المنظر اليمني للهويه
الروسيه ان المهمه الرئيسيه للزعيم هي
حمايه الناس والاراضي الواقعه تحت
السيطراتها واضاف دورين محذرا لا يمكن
للسلطات في روسيا تسليم اي شيء اخر وصلنا
الى الحد الاقصى طلب الحزب الشيوعي في
البرلمان الروسي والذي نادرا ما يتحدى
الكراملين بتفسير من وزاره الدفاع الاصدار
الامريكي بالانسحاب من خرسان لكن الاقتراح
نسفه حزب بوتن روسيا الموحده تكشف صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز ان بعض المحللين اشار الى
ان التصاعد الانتقادات يشير الى ان بوتن
فشله في ابعاد نفسه عن الانتكاسات
المتكرره في الحرب كابه لكن حجم
الانتقادات لم يصل بعد لتحميله المسؤوليه
بالكامل بعض اكثر الانتقادات الموجهه
للجيش اتت من حسابات مرتبطه بمرتزقه فاجنر
التي انتقد مؤسسها يفغيني بيجوزين
جينيرالات الجيش الروسي استدعى المتشككون
فيما اطلق عليه الكلامل مناوره خرسون
التاريخيه في انتقادهم يقولون ان
المدافعين في ستالينغراد ابان الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كان لديهم خيار التراجع
عبر نهر فولغا لكنهم لم يفعل ذلك بينما ما
حدث في خرسون هو العكس تمام جاء في
افتتاحيه صحيفه ميزه
فيزيمالايا الجازيتا ان قرارات بوتا ليست
للمناقشه وا لا يستطيع ان يخطئ لانه لا
توجد اليا للتصحيح لكن المشكله لدى بوتن
اعقد مما ذكرته الصحيفه فمعروف عن رجل
الكرملين القوي انه يرى ان القائد الذي
يعترف بالخطا يقلل من مكانته ما يجعل
صفاته موضع شئ في القانون الروسي انتقاد
الجيش بشكل مباشر يعتبر جريمه الا ان بوت
ان كان حتى الان متسامحا مع المتعصبين من
اليمين الذين انتقدوا روسيا باعتبارها لا
تقاتل بقوا كافيه هنا تسال عدد من
المعلقين ان كانوا قله لماذا لم تستخدم
روسيا ترى سنتها النوويه ولماذا لم يكن
الجيش الروسي يقصف الطرق في غرب اوكرانيا
المستخدمه لاستيراد الامدادات العسكريه من
الولايات المتحده واوروبا اسئله اذا معلقه
بانتظار اجوبه ذلك